you know nick foles could have been a
potential candidate to play quarterback
for the new england patriots bill
belichick saw up close a couple of years
ago what foals can do
but we don't know what the patriots are
doing at the quarterback position other
than not bringing back tom brady there's
a thought that maybe they're going to go
with jared stidham second year guy hey
it worked with a second year guy in 2001
right after drew bledsoe got blown up on
the sidelines by moe lewis but chris
what do we think the patriots will
ultimately do do you think they'll be in
the market now for andy dalton you know
peter king mentioned dalton to the
patriots so many times in the past
couple of months it makes me think he
knows something he says he doesn't which
is part of the ruse right that's part of
the setup no i don't know anything yeah
andy dalton to the patriots i think
would be a possibility but he's going to
want to be paid yeah i just wonder
whether or not bill belichick sees this
as a chance to reset the clock to the
days of having not much money right
invested in the quarterback position
reset the clock he's got a lot of draft
picks here they're going to reset the
team a little bit you know not that
they're tanking or rebuilding but he's
kind of refocusing the nucleus of this
team and and building you know not from
scratch but building something new here
mike i don't think they're gonna make
any play for for andy dalton or anything
like that i don't i just don't see them
trading away draft picks or paying him
extra money like that the sense i get i
know i've told you this during the
season and when we got into some of the
brady could leave talk uh that that
jared sidham's loved up there that i
mean he's they they think the world of
them they think he can be the next guy
and i think really what they'll do right
now is they're gonna stand pat and i
think ultimately they're gonna bring in
you know a a veteran backup you know
maybe does a brian hoyer maybe jacoby
bersette comes back into town you know
to be the backup somebody like that
though that that they feel like okay we
got a little familiarity if we got to
throw this guy in there that's great but
i don't think they're going to bring
anybody in to challenge challenge stim
as the starter i really think as all
things and signs point right now that
they're going to go with him this year
and that would be the ultimate bill
belichick thing to do anyways so that
that that's right up his alley so i'm
not shocked by that
and you wonder what the expectations
will be for the patriots already we've
seen the odds plummet or grow whichever
is the right direction but the buccaneer
is regarded as a better proposition than
the patriots at this point to get to the
super bowl which isn't surprising
because all the patriots done have done
in free agency is lose guys right i mean
i want one or two like random guys have
come in but some recognizable names are
are fleeing for
other outposts of the patriot way
whether it's detroit the giants or the
dolphins i mean the dolphins uh have
snagged multiple former patriots and
this is this is just strange to see
where this is going to go for the
patriots in 2020 and this will be the
ultimate test i guess if bill belichick
has to prove he can do it without tom
brady he's going to tear the whole thing
down so it's even more impressive if
he's able to get it done with unproven
players yeah well i think he's he's
playing the long play he's not going
like oh we're gonna try to do it all for
this year's team and i'm gonna prove
everybody wrong right here in 2020 that
i can do it without tom brady no i think
he's starting to build try to build you
know his next phase of a dynasty and it
might take a year or two maybe they
missed the playoffs i think they're
still going to be highly competitive
listen i'm not sitting here going oh man
they've lost some players here where
it's over for them they're really
screwed you know hey new england yeah we
got questions about the quarterback
position you know there's still things
to like about the offense do they need
to improve the o-line and things like
that yes but damn let's not forget
that's the best sec that was one of the
best defenses we've seen in a long time
last year we can't forget that aspect of
it where you know it's the maybe the
best corner duo in football one of the
best pass defenses we ever saw in the
history of football to where i still
think they're going to be able to rely
on them and not have to rely on a guy
like stidham to score 30 points on a
weekend week out basis they'll be a
defensive football team they'll play
smart they'll manage the offense and
they'll try to win 20 to 17 games kind
of like they did this year
yeah and look we know that bill
belichick is the master at coming up
with game plans and teaching it to his
guys and they don't have to be great
players if bill belichick puts them in
the right place and they can be trusted
to do their job so this is going to be
one hell of a chemistry experiment in
new england this year to see how the
post tom brady patriots fare and if they
really do rip it down there's going to
be no expectations then there is going
to be hell this team's not going to the
playoffs so if they just get to the
playoffs it's going to be viewed as
coach of the year type performance by
bill belichick chris yeah no it will and
i would not be shocked if they ended up
in the playoffs i am never going to
count the new england patriots out i
know tom brady's not there and that's a
little scary but still you know let's
not forget this is a team that went 14-6
without tom brady when he didn't play
you know and one of those losses was
with a third string quarterback a third
stringer you know they went 11-5 with a
guy who didn't even play college
football i mean that to me is still
astounding and i know that was a really
good team around them but yeah i do not
expect the new england patriots to fall
off earth am i picking them to win the
afc's i don't know about that but i
think they're going to be highly
competitive
most likely i am yes
yeah and i think i will too with stefan
diggs and with the continued growth and
development of josh allen right and that
defense under sean mcdermott yeah i
think i'm going to take the bills
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports